glad you're back the social media
network parlor now fighting against
criticism that failed to flag threats
about the deadly capital attack now
today parlor saying it alerted the fbi
multiple times
to violent content on his platform they
even said 50 times that before
january 6. attorneys for parliament
making its case in a letter to congress
on the same day the ceos of facebook
twitter and google were grilled on
capitol hill for the first time
since that riot and the brings us to
this question did twitter facebook and
amazon destroy parlor
the fastest growing social media outlet
in america because they couldn't control
it
joining us now to discuss this and more
tim poole journalist self-proclaimed
disaffected liberal and he's got a great
podcast tim what do you think
why why was paul taken down the same day
the president was
parlor was growing too fast it was
creating an alternate space for many
conservative personalities and the
pressure was so great
even i recognized i needed to have a
profile there so
i started posting a little bit less on
twitter i still use it i still use
these other platforms but the big the
defining factor of whether or not one of
these companies will succeed
is critical mass it was very clear that
finally conservatives found a platform
where they were gaining that critical
mass
i think these companies panicked you
take a look at where all these companies
are located they're all in similar areas
in silicon valley
and we've seen this pattern of abuse
before from these companies these guys
know each other these vcs
i would assume most of the most of them
are friends it happened with
patreon for instance this is a
subscriber platform where
people who make podcasts or art can tell
their fans to sign up and give a little
bit to support their work
they banned a a podcast or a youtuber
named carl benjamin
when he moved over to another rival
called subscribe star
all of a sudden they saw their financial
services terminated at the exact same
time different companies
it's no surprise to me parlor actually
challenged
twitter and what you see from from these
tech companies facebook youtube twitter
they control the space they control the
speech
think about what's going on with this
pandemic you can't go outside you can't
go to the bars you can't hang out with
your friends all of these rules
you're forced to communicate online but
they restrict certain opinions that
normal people have
it's almost like they're engineering the
conversation whether it's intentional or
not
parlor gave a space to those other
opinions
and they they nuked it just what they
did tim is almost you have a choice you
could be instagram and whatsapp and get
bought by the big guys or get destroyed
they're destroyed by the big guys right
now donald trump within uh i think a few
weeks is going to be launching on
another platform
are they going to try to take that
platform whatever it turns out to be
take that down
now this is interesting right i i
honestly think they did not want to
remove trump but it got to the point
where the political pressure was too
great
and then they did before donald trump
joined twitter
twitter was losing users they were
changing their metrics this is my
understanding of what was going on and
donald trump you know i should say
before he ran for president
once he starts running for president he
dominates the news cycle then people saw
the trump bump media companies latched
on to every single tweet he had
since donald trump has been off social
media and out of the news cycle they've
still
talked about the man but there's not
enough we're seeing the ratings drop
across the board for everybody and
remarkably
seems fox news for the most part has
kind of just stayed where it was
in terms of ratings but cnn msnbc abc
everyone's going down
so i wonder if donald trump does come
back
will they feign a kind of oh no oh
donald trump's back
but secretly want him to be back because
his tweets his posts means
they can write all these same stories
again claim trumpism is taking over the
country and it's a big threat to
everybody
try to get their ratings back up he
might be watching now he might bring
that up with lauren a few hours tonight
kind of interesting he says that you
know what the more i think of it i like
the idea of a press release it's more
elegant
maybe i should have tweeted less we'll
never know tim thanks so much
tim poole thanks